welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain it is my pleasure to
introduce to you dr. vision hassan dr.
Peston is interested in understanding
large-scale circuits in the brain and
how to engineer novel brain based
therapies he was trained in physics and
made the switch to neuroscience as a
postdoctoral fellow he's been on the
faculty at NYU since 2006 raising
associate professor of neuroscience at
the Center for Neuroscience for more
information on our speaker please look
at the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Preston's talk title is human
brain science the intersection of
translational neuro technology and
systems neuroscience my name is dr.
Rebecca Shannon and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bringing this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth we'd
like to extend our special thanks to the
brain initiative program directors and
in particular dr. James nag for their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by so
many questions during the presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type and type your questions in the
drive and the drop down box our speaker
will respond to your questions by email
following the presentation the
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without any further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. BJ
personal I'll be talking about human
brain science the intersection of
translational neuro technology and
systems neuroscience one of the most
important things that infuses our work
is the idea that the non-human primate
is a model of the human brain provides
us with a model of the human brain and
what I'm showing you on this slide is a
rendering to scale of two MRI images of
the rhesus macaque monkey on the left
and the human
brain on the right what's important
about these mr. this is this image is
that the monkey brain is only two and a
half times smaller in each dimension
than that of the human approximately
that gives us about a 10 to 15 factor 10
to 15 difference in size and this is
captured by the weights of the two
brains the numbers of neurons in the
brains and the number of neurons in the
cortex of each of these brains and so
this is a really important image for us
because it shows how similar the monkey
brain is to the human brain and allows
us to develop our technologies in the
monkey in a way that can be directly
translated to humans another really
important aspect to our work is the
nature of the signals that we're
recording and analyzing and this slide
what I'm showing you are three different
recording technologies that are
currently used to study the human brain
the EEG which is shown and measured at
the scalp with a one centimeter size
electrode energy which is measured using
a special sensor which is outside the
scalp and even further away they
measures magnetic fields and inside the
brain with the invasive measurements
available in a select population for
clinical purposes we can measure the
electric cortical gram or ACOG signal
and that signal is made at the surface
of the brain under the dura and with an
electrode that's about four millimeters
in size so the technologies that allow
these measurements invasively within the
brain are shown on the right
they are the subdural cortical electrode
which is shown in the top left panel
it's a grid and the depth electrodes
which penetrate into the brain and are
shown below and each one of these probes
has a specificity of around many
millimeters and space by typically
something like a centimeter when we
consider the ability to record
near liked to be more directly we can
need to think about the micro recordings
and so now what I'm sure
instead of recording types you can make
by going into the brain at a finer scale
so I'm showing you the micro aqaq which
is measured at the same location as the
E [ __ ] signal but with a recording
electrode that's only a hundred microns
and then we have the laminar electrodes
in the micro electrode and the only
federally approved device that can
perform these kinds of invasive
recordings clinically is the Utah right
then that records spiking and fill
potentials so there's a big gap between
what we can do
invasively at the micro scale and this a
more macro ukog scale so what I want to
talk about today is how we can bridge
this gap and I'll start by talking about
how to interpret the measurements we can
make before moving on to considering the
computations performed by the brain and
how we can analyze them and then how we
can translate the new technologies from
monkeys to humans so interpreting
large-scale brain dynamics using field
potentials which is how we record the
signals I've just talked about depends
on having a model for understanding the
measurement the biophysical forward
model is the model which generates from
the source signals in the brain the
field potentials that we can measure and
that by physical model is informed by
our understanding of cellular biophysics
and electricity magnetism in physics so
we have different types of cells and we
can record the activity on the axons and
dendrites axon shown in red dendrite
shown in blue and what's important about
this model is that it teaches us that
when we have for example these stellate
cells which are found in layer 4 they
have large axonal dendrites excuse me
external extents but small dendritic
extents and this type of geometry gives
rise to a small field potential in
response to synaptic input in contrast
the other type of neuron that I'm
showing you here at cortical neuron the
layer 5 pyramid generates large
potentials because the axons are not
weighted so much by the foot potential
measurement and the dendrites are
extended and this is what creates a
large signal that we can measure with an
now the biophysical Ford model isn't the
most important Ford model to our work
what we also care about is how
computations are being performed and so
to understand that we have to consider
what we call a functional Ford model so
the functional Ford model considers the
actual selectivity of neural activity in
the brain and how that gives rise to
selectivity in our measurements and so
what we have here are two examples of
selectivity which is organized on the
left with the arrows showing the spatial
coding of a variable involved in
behavior that smoothly changes as you
move across the cortical surface and the
measurements we make for field
potentials in those situations would
pool across these neighboring
measurement signals and give rise to a
large amplitude response in the
functional Ford model while if the
signals are not smoothly varying in the
selectivity across the sheet then we
would get cancellation effectively of
the signals and small amplitude
selectivity so an EEG signal might give
us the video alone are measurements
because it a verge of or large enough
regions of the brain that the topography
is lost while a micro eco measurement or
a field potential a local field
potential measurement measured more
close to the source more selectively may
give us a larger amplitude signal so
these ideas are how we think about the
interpretation of the philodendron
measurements now the computations that
we're interested in are informed by our
understanding of behavior and how the
brain controls behavior in the animal
model and the monkeys we've been
studying the visually guided behaviors
and this is illustrated here where we
have vision entering the brain guiding
actions and then being used in this case
to guide looking movement by movements
and arm movements conceptually the way
we analyze these computations is in
terms of sensory and motor maps we think
of the eyes as being seeing the world
around us and the sensory cues in that
world and when those cues are to
instruct actions then we need to
transform those sensory cues intermodal
commands or intended movements and so
the transformation that we're interested
in goes from the sensory map to the
motor map and in the case of an eye
movement we can think of this quite
literally as the map of the world where
there are stimuli in it and then the
need to move the eyes to acquire those
stimuli the kinds of behavioral tasks
that we can use so study this our
correspondingly quite simple we have a
monkey staring at a screen he has a cue
that he remembers the location of
following short delay he moved his eyes
to that remembered location and we find
that neurons in the brain fire rapidly
and in response to the presentation of
the cue throughout the delay and then
turn off after the movement as we vary
where the cues presented in space we
find different types of responses from
the same neuron in this example this
neuron prefers or encodes space down and
to the right of where when he's looking
and the other locations are not as well
encoded by the neurons activity now
these neuronal signals are quite hard to
record and impede which impedes our
ability to translate technologies based
on their activity work done in my lab
and earlier has shown that field
potentials the field potentials we've
just been talking about also contains
detailed information about the processes
involving sensory motor transformations
here I'm showing you two spectrograms
which show us the power in the signal as
the monkey is doing the task with the
cue onset time being shown at C the
psychotic eye movement being shown at s
and we can see that as we move through
time and frequency there are ranges of
power in frequency ranges of power and
frequencies between 30 to 80 Hertz which
are increased when the monkey wants to
look to what we call the preferred
duration for that site compared to the
anti preferred direction when we
quantify the selectivity of the field
potentials and compare it with the
selectivity of the firing rate of
neurons we see that there
very similar the firing rate of the
neuron and the potential power R
similarly tuned so this shows that we
can analyze neural computations involved
with sensory motor behaviors using field
potentials instead of only recording
neurons so how can we apply this to
study functions of the human brain that
are unique
well speech is uniquely human faculty
and we've been in discussion with them
in the field there is this idea that the
similar computational mechanisms support
speech as these other sensory motor
behaviors and so david poeppel a pioneer
in neurolinguistics
advised me to study speech as if a
monkey could talk and the reason for
this is the in a model that he and his
colleague Greg Hickok have developed
these sensory motor transformations for
speech are organized in the brain
similarly to that of the other sensory
motor transformations in animals and so
this diagram just shows the range of
interactions across the two different
hemispheres in the human brain
supporting speech processing
conceptually the idea remains the same
computational idea remains the same we
have a perceptual map for speech it gets
transformed into a motor map that we use
to make an utterance to speak and the
relationship between these two maps and
how the computations connect them to go
from sensation to action is the type of
computation that we can analyze based on
work in animals and so the strategy for
studying speeches of the monkey to talk
is to present stimuli that the animal
hears in this case the human hears and
then speaks based on in this case just
repeats and so the task is to listen to
the sound and then repeat the word that
you hear you can also have a condition
where you just listen to the sound
without speaking so that you can hear it
but just to mime it and there's a listen
speaking listen mind conditions are
really important for isolating sensory
motor processes processes relate to
sensation and action and not just
sensation or action we performed a set
of studies to record the
acog signal in human subjects epilepsy
patients who are having electrodes
implanted for clinical purposes and we
find that we can see sites in the brain
which respond to the movement to utter
really respective of whether or not the
subjects making any noise they're not
speaking they're just moving their mouth
we also get other responses which are
selected for hearing the sounds but not
speaking the sounds they can also hear
themselves speak in the left panel and
then we have these sensory motor
responses which connect sensation in
action by responding both to the hearing
and the speech for each condition even
when miming and so this set of results
pointed to the existence of a sensory
motor speech system that linked
perceptual inputs and motor outputs and
we've hypothesized that along with
others that this interface the sensory
motor interface supports access to the
linguistic processes which we need to
ascribe meaning to our speech the
results associated with this study were
quite important because they showed in
fact that these responses were bilateral
that is to say they were found in both
the left and the right hemisphere which
was not expected based on the work of
hikakin poeple and others indicating
that our understanding of how this level
of speech processing is lateralized is
incomplete and points are the kinds of
new findings we can make about the
organization of neural computations in
the human brain using fill potentials so
now I want to move on to our ability to
analyze these neural computations using
next-generation devices in particular I
want to talk about so-called flexible
printed circuit board tech based
technologies and the reason why is
because they're really powerful for
translational goals
these devices are microfabricated
they're cheap and low-cost they're
available for manufacturing commercially
they are also able to be used to make
biocompatible implants and critically
since they're based on printed circuit
boards we can
great more advanced electronic circuits
that make the devices wireless and smart
so we've done a number of studies to
test these devices in our monkeys the
way we've done this is to revise how we
think about the testing cycle instead of
pairing and training animals and then
implanting a device and seeing how it
does revising the device and then
implanting it again in a different
animal we developed a system whereby we
could package the device shown in panel
E and then place the inside and implants
shown in panel D and F that allows us to
prepare one animal and then implant many
devices rapidly this is because we don't
need to re implant-- the animal
surgically we can do it while they're
awake we've also used the system to
record wirelessly overnight and here I'm
showing you an ode what we call it's a K
each system that has a wireless antennas
on it and then we added a wireless
transmitter to the previous assembly
that I showed you what recording these
signals overnight allowed us to do is to
study for the first time these signals
in naturally sleeping monkeys and what
we can do is look at the sleep dynamics
so this is a different kind of activity
than what we've been talking about but
illustrates the power of this approach
of recording the micro eco signals on
those electrodes and so in this slide
what I'm showing you are the different
types of phenomena that we've observed
where we see signals which are present
both on the spiking of the neurons the
field potentials inside the brain and on
the II cog near and far and that's in
the global example it's present on all
the contacts we recorded from in this
experiment at the same time we also have
ever see other kinds of responses which
are local which is to say they're on the
II cog and they're on the LFP but not
they're not on all the e cogs and
channels there's a blue the far ACOG is
silent in this case during the event we
can also find other events which
more found on the field potentials then
on either of the e [ __ ] signals and
finally we can see events that propagate
across the cortical sheep and in fact
from the depths of the brain to the
surface of the brain all of this is to
show how well the micro eco seconds can
whistle resolve high resolution signals
in sleeping brain which is previously
only been studied using more macroscopic
measurements like EEG that do not
resolve these different kinds of
responses most recently we've been
taking these devices and testing them in
patients with epilepsy again but instead
of recording the e cog signal we're
recording the micro eco Google using our
new device here I'm showing you
intraoperative recordings of the micro
eco signal during seizure related events
and this shows about a hundred of the
electrodes that we're recording from and
you can see as you go down through these
different electrodes which are spaced
quite closely the activity is changing
across these different contacts quite
dramatically
you see events coming and going as you
move across the sheet and now I want to
show you a video of this data the same
data that I'm showing you in the time
series but now as a movie and you'll see
the different colors showing the
different voltages of the signal over
time
you
so what I hope you can see in that movie
is the the activity across the all the
different contacts is swirling and very
dynamic and rich with structure in ways
that we could not have observed if we
had not made the measurement the way
that we did that is to say with high
resolution using the micro electrode
array and this is really important for
clinical applications because the
different types of events need to be
diagnosed differently and the treatment
that the patients will receive should
reflect this diagnosis then in
conclusion I've told you about how Phil
potentials can be used to interpret and
understand the organization of brain
activity and the functional forward
model is a very important concept for
this because it allows us to interpret
the selectivity in the signals and how
we use them to understand neural
computations I've also shown you how we
can develop a framework for analyzing
your computations that's been used to
study visually guided behaviors and
animals and to do so for what is a
uniquely human faculty that of speech
I've presented how we can translate new
technologies that are low cost and high
resolution that will allow us to resolve
dynamics in more detailed ways than we
could before and offer new treatment
paradigms we hope thank you very much
thank you dr. Peston for that excellent
talk as a reminder our speaker will
follow up any questions about his
presentation by email
continuing with our innovative
neurotechnologies track we have the
outstanding dr. Georges Ozaki presenting
next Doctor Who sakis top title is high
resolution recording and non-invasive
perturbation tools for the human brain
hope to see you there